but i think that's the same the cat
movement because that's the moment where
you realize that
chris knight is going to
help this kid adjust
to life at this school
you know you love the film real genius
with val kilmer what is the save the cat
moment in that film
i think it's probably
okay
so with real genius
uh
the premise there's a young genius
who enrolls in this uh sort of like cal
tech
type school
and he partners up with chris knight
who's played by val kilmer
and he's young like the
this kid is like 14 or 15 years old you
know he's young and he's surrounded by
all these older students
they're picking on him whatever
and he places a phone call to his
parents
complaining about the school he's crying
mom i don't want to be here
and
the call is recorded and broadcast like
i think in the cafeteria
you know and he's humiliated this this
kid is humiliated
and
he doesn't know what to do
val kilmer
says hey
don't get mad get even
and he helps him concoct his plan you
know to get revenge on like the main
bully
which is uh this guy named kent
it's so funny that this film
everyone at the school is a nerd
essentially but they still have the
different factions you've got the cool
kids you got your bullies or whatever
so the main bully kent they devised his
plan to get revenge on him
and they do it by essentially
dismantling his car
and reassembling it in his dorm room
where it's like sitting on this
inflatable
raft or whatever
it's it's it's it's great it's great
because it it works for the world with
that film as well you know it's it's so
absurd but it works the world of that
film you know ken he just he loves his
car and everything um
but i think that's the same the cat
moment because that's the moment where
you realize that
kris knight is going to
help this kid adjust
to life at the school
you know that's the moment i think you
really
like him because he can come off as a
bit insufferable in the beginning like
when we when we're first introduced to
him he's actually
interviewing for a job
and he's wearing alien antenna
and bunny slippers
and it was a halloween costume that i
wore one year actually it's it's it's
it's fantastic
you see just he just doesn't care
he doesn't care but when he helps out
you know the new kid
when he helps the kid get revenge on the
bully
that's when you see
he does care about something
i think that's his save the cat moment
interesting so he's always been super
smart he doesn't really have to worry
about he always figures things out
exactly
and so then you see sort of this
humanity come out of him
helping this other kid that was being
bullied
okay i like that
when you saw the guy on the corner
selling save the cat you buy the book
you read it
how has it impacted your work
even to this day
well as i as i mentioned you know
that book blake snyder what he did is he
he turned
a lot of the elements that
i think should be in the script right
for instance dark knight of the soul
it's something that
i've seen in every
just about every movie that i've watched
that i've read in just about every story
i just didn't know what it was called i
or i just you know didn't have anything
to call it but i knew the moment
so
the book termed all of these elements
and that helped me realize oh
that's what's happening here that's why
it's happening here
this is why we should have this
and so i've been
a lot more
cognizant of
you know how i'm using these elements
where i'm placing them in my own scripts
in my own writing making sure just just
being aware of you know me using those
elements
and
you know just making sure that they're
placed properly
in my script because you can't have a
dark knight in the soul at the beginning
of you know
that doesn't work
and then a real genius what is the dark
dawn of the soul is that where the one
character calls the parents no i would
say the dark night of the soul is when
they realize what the professor
has done
uh
they they learn that the professor
their professor is using their work to
craft a laser to essentially like
assassinate people from space
and they realize okay we've solved this
issue
and he's taken it
you know to the government
what what can we do
that i think that's the dark night of
the soul
it's because i mean even val kilmer you
know uh his character chris knight
is despondent
you know he has a mini breakdown and and
they they kept the
their solution was to essentially like
freeze the laser
and they kept it and um in the freezer
in the in the break room and he has a
breakdown he's you know beating on the
on the refrigerator and he slumps down
like i can't believe it
he says i was a fool
but then
there's the moment where you know they
realize what they can do
in order to sabotage the professor and
that's how they come out of the uh the
dark knight
of the soul
so how does this professor get them to
come up with ideas he presents this
potential laser
yeah um
i mean i guess i'm fuzzy on the details
but
he has them working on a laser project
like they they all know it's a laser and
they're trying different methods like
there was one method i remember that
that uses a mirror of some sort um but i
think i if if i'm remembering correctly
the problem was that the laser was was
too hot like they they couldn't regulate
the temperature and that's where they
got the idea to freeze the the mechanism
that fires the laser but because
i know because it was so intense or
whatever um
it was only good for a limited amount of
time maybe like two seconds or something
like that you know
uh
yeah i'm fuzzy on the science i want to
see it again i think i think i have seen
it but it was a gazillion years ago and
now now it'll be part of movie night i
like that jay let's say you were writing
a screenplay and you go through it and
you say i'm missing some beats according
to blake snyder's save the cat
what would you do
i mean i think it's honestly i think
it's difficult to
to miss any of the beats because they're
so dependent on each other
for instance
you've got the catalyst
and the catalyst is supposed to be the
life-changing event for the protagonist
and then after that is the debate
and the debate
is essentially the protagonists deciding
on
what action they're going to take
with regard to the catalyst
you know i think because the beats are
so dependent on each other even if
even if you
forget about one or two
there's they're still going to be
present the script they've got to be i
just think that
inherently they're part of the story
you know you're going to have
that that dark night uh of the soul
it just happens in every story because
in every story the protagonist gets
defeated
you know the they're you know the goal
that they're chasing what they're trying
to do they get thwarted
at some point
and they feel low about it
um
it just happened so i don't know that i
don't know that you can really
leave out a beat or miss a beat it's
there
even if it's not strong like it's there
you know perhaps you'll have to go back
and think oh wait a minute this is
supposed to be
okay
and maybe punch it up but but i think i
think the beats are there
they should be there yeah